مساء الخير تعلمون أن الشعبوية هي أ
استراتيجية صاخبة
وفي روح الدعابة الشعبوية الجيدة أ
استفزاز لخلق ضجة و
إغواء جمهور الناخبين
أكثر وأكثر حساسية لأطروحاته
هذا الاستفزاز الأخير ودعوته
لحظر الأسماء العربية
هناك أيضا هو nogueira ويتولى مسؤولية
بدعة سيده في التفكير بصراحة
هذا الأخير من شأنه أن يرضي أيضًا في النهاية
من القرن التاسع عشر تكاثر
غير اليهود
يسير على خطاه ويموت
تحية لارتفاع نابليون بونابرت
قانون 11 جرثومية في
1 أبريل 1803 تتطلب الوالدين
لإعطاء أسماء مسيحية لهم
أطفال زمور يريدون استعادة هذا القانون
ويأسف أن اليسار في السلطة
1993 إزالتها
على أي حال كل ما هو عربي يعطي
ألحان من القاهرة إلى زمور بجانب
يسمي اللغة العربية نفسها أولاً
تعتبر غير متوافقة مع
العقلانية باتباع المؤرخ أ
إرنست رينان أو الحمضيات
قرن
هذا اللسان المشدود اليوم
الملل ببساطة ناقلات
الانفصالية الإسلامية
خامس أكثر لغة منطوقة في
العالمية
اللغة العربية هي اللغة الثالثة
الاقتراض من الفرنسية وراء الإنجليزية
والإيطالية
لكن كل هذا لا يبالي زمور
تجاهل أن هناك في اللغة الفرنسية
خمس مرات كلمة أراكي من الطحلب لك
لغة أسلافنا الإغريق
في كل 60 ألف كلمة
تشكل جوهر اللغة
الفرنسية هناك 500 - الراب لا شيء سوى
الصباح على الإفطار الذي تستخدمه
أربعة أشهر
لديك فنجان من القهوة
كلمة تامب كلمة قهوة كلمتان
الى
ستضيف السكر إلى قهوتك
وكلمة سكر و هموار
بعد تناول عصير البرتقال
كلمة برتقالي هي أيضا كلمة عربية
كانوا قادرين على قضاء وقت ممتع في عد كلمة ياسمين
هو لي كلمة الغيتار والهاموار
الخروف كلمة عربية
وهناك عشرات من كلمات العلماء
كلمة الجبر من الواضح أن الكلمة العربية
الخوارزمية هي كلمة عربية الكلمة
كيمياء وكلمة عربية
علامة @ التي نستخدمها في رسائل البريد الإلكتروني الخاصة بنا
انها تأتي من الاسبانية لروبن الذي
نفسها تأتي من محرم عليه
هذا مقياس قديم لما
اعتبر موسى بن ميمون العظيم
الرهان الثاني الذي كان طبيب
كتب salavat عمله الرئيسي
دليل الضائع بالعربي الى العام
ألف 100 90
على بصمات اللسان
اللغة العربية الفرنسية أرسل لك مرة أخرى
إلى كتاب المعجم الرائع
سعر جان الفرنسية يذهب أسلافنا
العرب أيضا في كتاب
وزير الثقافة السابق و
التعليم الوطني جاك لانج
بعنوان كنز اللغة العربية
فرنسا
لسوء الحظ لزمور
لحسن الحظ للبشرية
كلمة روايته للطيور ويكون عنده
لا يوجد جواز سفر أو تأشيرة مطلوبة
لاجل السفر
وحول مسألة اللغات فكاهة
ليس فقط كاره للعرب
يقرأ أيضًا اللغة الإنجليزية
في 15 أكتوبر ونشرها في
تويتر نريد أن نحافظ على
أجمل لغة في العالم
واضح أننا نريد حمايتها منها
الثراء الأمريكي
شمال إفريقيا والألبان الصلبة
شامل
طوال تاريخها
لطالما كانت فرنسا أرضًا
سيكون له ممر
حيث كل من اللهجات و
اللهجات
البعض الآخر ليس في تاريخ فرنسا
تاريخ اللغة الفرنسية
ولادة اللغة الفرنسية
يعود تاريخه إلى 842 وقسم
كان ستراسبورغ صديق اللاتين الطويل
من صباح اللغات الغالية
الجرماني
علاوة على ذلك مؤسس فرنسا اليورو
من قبل أن يغني الفرنك الألماني
مطارق تشارلز العزيزة على سيدي
زمور الذي أوقف الفتح العربي في
poitiers عام 732 حيث حفيده
توج شارلمان إمبراطورًا في العام
800 شخصية ضخمة من العصور الوسطى الأوروبية
في مطالبة فرنسا وألمانيا
هذه الدراسة الأخيرة حول ما
معجب بالحضارة العربية
مسلم
في ماذا ولكن كل قصة
الفيل الأبيض في vonnas abbès who
كهدية دبلوماسية ل
شارلمان من قبل الخليفة العباسي آل
رشيد
حول جوان بورك تعافى المعبود
أما اليمين المتطرف فلم يتكلم
فرنسي
علينا أن ننتظر القرن السادس عشر و
فرانسوا 1er حتى أن اللغة
أصبحت الفرنسية اللغة الرسمية
للأمة في
لقرون
لاتينية بريتون الفلمنكية
بورجوندي بيكار بروفانس بعد
سنوات جاس في التعايش مع الفرنسيين
في جميع أنحاء فرنسا
السيد الزموري أحادي اللغة له فقط
نافذة على العالم واللغة
الفرنسية وأقل أو الروحانية
هل يعرف أنه سجن طويل الأمد
هذا لروبرت الرجل الذي لعب
دور رئيسي في تاريخ
تفقد القواميس الفرنسية اسمها
العربة الجوالة الكبيرة والصغيرة واحدة وسوداء
لكن في الجزائر حيث أمضى 40 عامًا
امتدت حياته إلى اللغة
الفرنسية واللغة العربية و
إنجليزي
للأسف إنه أيضًا زمور أصلي
الجزائري لن يستفيد من هذا
ثروة لغوية وثقافية لا
ما الذي سيفعله خيار أيديولوجي
والتي تتمثل في رفض أصولها
الأفريقي والبربر ل
استيعاب الهوية أثناء وجوده
لقب زمور هو كلمة
البربر ماذا يعني أوليفر
شجع أطفالك على التعلم
اللغات الأجنبية والانفتاح على
موقع ثقافات أخرى عظيم
ما زال يخبره بالثروة شارلمان
لتوحيد لغتنا هو امتلاك
ثانية
الأكثر خطورة في جيمو سيسون
التحريفية
مهووس بالتآمر و
مشغول بالتلاعب بالتاريخ قبل كل شيء
تاريخ الحرب العالمية الثانية
ونظام فيشي هو نفسه
ما في وسعه لإعادة تأهيل
المارشال بيتان بتناول أطروحة
درع الكرة الأرضية للمؤرخ روبرت
هارون
وفقًا لأطروحته عن المارشال بيتان و
كان الجنرال دي غول كلاهما
ضروري لفرنسا المارشال و
درع لحماية نفسك
لهم الجنرال سيف القتال
نصف سينتقد بقسوة من قبل
المؤرخ الأمريكي روبرت باكستون
ارتفاع فرنسا القماش القطني
1944 صدر كتاب باكستون في فرنسا
في عام 1973 سيكون أصل
الثورة والفريوغرافيا في فرنسا
سميت على اسم ثورة العبوة
حجري
مع باكستون مارشال بيتان هناك
يظهر تحت ستار
الاعتماد على كبار الموظفين
المحفوظات الألمانية التي استعادها
الحلفاء في نهاية الحرب روبرت
سيجد باكستون أن نظام فيشي قد فعل ذلك
تعاونت بنشاط مع النازيين الذين
مشروع الحل النهائي الاستماع إلى
الصوريين الأمريكي روبرت باكستون أو
في البداية كان يعتقد أن الإدارة
فرنسي
تطبيق هذه الإجراءات المعادية لليهود
نظام فيشي ربما على مضض
وكان قبل كل شيء أيديولوجيين
مكتب الشؤون اليهودية التي
دفعها للقيام بذلك بشكل جيد في
المحفوظات نرى أن كل شيء
الإدارة الفرنسية للتقدم
هذه القوانين في بعض الأحيان مع ليس كثيرا
الفرح مع قليل من الرفض ولكن
أصروا على أن الأسطح دولة
يجب أن يكون
جادل بأن القانون بحاجة إلى تعزيز
الألمان لم يطلبوا ذلك
بقدر ما أراد الألمان كل شيء
فعل شيئًا آخر في عام 1940 ماذا فعل
أراد أنه يريد طردهم
يهود فرنسا في فرنسا لا
مشغول لذا فهو لا يريد فرنسا
الذين كانوا معاديين لليهود
لم تكن رغبتهم فيما بعد
أشياء أخرى في غضون عامين
ابتدأت الابادة معك
كتب ، علاوة على ذلك ، أن الألمان
فكر أولاً في فعل و
هتلر أتخيل أن النظام بأكمله يفكر فيه
جعل فرنسا نوعا ما
تفريغ عليك أن تضع الكلمة بين
ونقلت بالطبع لا تؤذي
اي شخص
نوع من مكبات اليهود
لكن المواطن الآن ولكن بعد
كانت الهدنة في خريف 40
تواصل السلطات الألمانية
عذرا في فرنسا يهود ألمانيا
نفس الأسبوع لجبل السلطات
تم طرد الألمان من أرض الراين 6000
يهود في المنطقة المحتلة هؤلاء الفقراء
وصل إلى قفص الاتهام بعد بضعة أيام
من التجوال في معسكر الجور وهم
غادرنا مشمئزين
3 م لأوشفيتز
حتى بن 40 الألمان يقولون ذلك
بدون فترة تم خلاصهم
إذا جاز لي القول في الاقتباسات من قبل
الألمان ثم السلطات
أرسلت الفرنسية نعم مذهلة
لكن تم طردهم من قبل
الألمان ومن هنا أرادوا شخصين
سنوات أقنعت الألمان بالاستئناف
اللاجئ ثم عام 1942 أخذ الألمان
فجأة قال هكذا نحن أنت
أخذ كل يهود فرنسا و
لطالما فكر الفرنسيون في
أرسلوا لجأوا إلى ألمانيا
بالنسبة لهم كانت أزمة اللاجئين
بالنسبة لنا هو بداية
shoah ثم كتابك من الواضح
كتاب كبير جدا وكامل جدا عن
الموضوع ويمكننا أن نرى بوضوح من الداخل
عملية القماش القطني وهو متى
حتى لأنها موجودة دائمًا
سؤال نطرحه على أنفسنا هنا يوجد
العديد من الأسئلة التي تنشأ
بالطبع من المسؤول
هل هي لافال نفسها
هذا الشيء اللعين الذي يمكن رؤيته يأخذ
هل هناك قرارات أم أنها كذلك
لافال الذي سيقرر الطرد في
نهاية طرد اليهود و
لمنح الكثير من الأشياء
لكننا نرى الألمان اليوم
أن القبطان يتطابق مع نفسه
يعتقد مع العديد من الفرنسيين أنه
كان هناك الكثير من اليهود في فرنسا
ترى الآن أن بيتان نفسه
أراد طرد اليهود من
إدارة التدريس
اقتصاد الثقافة الفرنسية لأن
أن هناك نهاية الثلاثينيات مع
هناك الكثير من الفرنسيين المحافظين
يعتقد أن هناك الكثير من اليهود و
قارن ما تعتقد أنه بسبب ذلك
أن هناك أولا الجبهة الشعبية
لذلك الصندوق الشعبي
في فكرة الحق هناك
بالإضافة إلى ذلك هو انتصار اليهود
وصول المهاجرين الذين وصلوا
لاجئين في وقت كانت فيه فرنسا
أضعفها الكساد الفرنسي
الذين ليس لديهم عمل يرون ذلك يحدث
من شرق أوروبا الأشخاص الذين لديهم
نفس مهنة ومن يعمل
لذلك في نفس الوقت يرى الفرنسيون
أن تصدق أن السينما
كل ذلك الأدب
تلعب مصر دورًا كبيرًا
عظيم وتلك الثقافة الفرنسية في
يعاني حتى هكذا نقرأ الصحافة
من أواخر الثلاثينيات من القرن الماضي إذا كان هو نفسه
حتى الكتاب
من هم الوسطيون ليسوا بالضرورة مضطرين لذلك
على حق لديه هذه الفكرة القوية جدًا
اليهود في خطر على فرنسا
ويسبب الحرب مع فرط هم
سيئة للوظيفة التي هم عليها
سيء للثقافة وفرنسا في
مقدمة
مباشرة بعد توقيع الهدنة
مع الألمان في يونيو 1940
بدأ نظام فيشي في اتخاذ
الإجراءات المعادية لليهود الصادرة في الفئة 2
وضع اليهود العنصريين و
التمييزية بين عامي 1940 و 1940 و
22 يوليو 1940 مرسوم بقانون بشأن
مراجعة التجنس أكثر من
سبعة آلاف يهودي تم تجنيسهم
27 أغسطس
1940 إلغاء قانون مارشاندو
21 أبريل 1939 الذي حظر
دعاية نخفيها في الصحافة
3 أكتوبر 1940 قانون
فرائض اليهود التي تنادي
لأول مرة مفهوم العرق اليهودي
هذا القانون يستثني اليهود على الإطلاق
مناصب في الخدمة المدنية وفي
المهن الفنية
في 4 أكتوبر 1940 ، منح قانون
يحافظ على قوة الإنترنت
الأجانب من العرق اليهودي
سيكون ضمن إطار هذا القانون
ضع جولة الشتاء بين 16
بين 16 و 17 يوليو 1942 خلال
خمسة أيام من شرطة نظام القماش القطني
القبض على أكثر من 13000 شخص بما في ذلك
ما يقرب من ثلث الأطفال
ترسل بالقطار بدون ماء أو طعام
إلى معسكر أوشفيتز في الواقع
كان نظام فيشي جناحًا مسلحًا المضي قدمًا
زمور ليقول لنفسه أن النظام الغذائي
فيشي ضحى باليهود الأجانب
لإنقاذ يهود فرنسا باسم
التعددية الوطنية بينما
تم استهداف يهود فرنسا ب
1940 هذا التمييز المدقع بين
يهود فرنسا يهود أجانب من
جزء من الفكاهة يقودني للتحدث معك
دراما اثنين من كبار المفكرين الألمان
من القرن العشرين الأجانب يحبون
تحفظات على المثقفين اللذين
هو ظهور النازية
طرق المنفى هذا عن حنة
أرندت وفالتر بنيامين
في المنزل لجأ إلى فرنسا و
وصل باريس عام 1933
في مايو 1944 تم اعتقالها مع
آلاف النساء في مخيم غورس غورس
دواء من المقاطع مثل النحيب
من لا يخرج من حلقه فاكتب له
راجان
تمكن الفيلسوف الشاب من الهروب
الانضمام إلى مونتوبان ثم مرسيليا حيث
إنها تحصل على الشكر للمراكز
إغاثة الأمريكيين تأشيرة ل
البرتغال حيث ستصل
الشروع في الولايات المتحدة في مايو
1941 بتأشيرة دخول والفوز بها
1 سوف تحصل أرنت على الجنسية
أمريكي وسيصبح عظيما
فيلسوف
ولديها فكرة عمل
تميز تركت لنا
أصول الشمولية
لقد تركت لنا رجل الثلج لجوريس ألين
تركت لنا أزمة
حضاره
غادرنا
صحيفة شرق فرنسا
للأسف
والباخ ​​بنيامين لم يكن لديه نفس الشيء
حظ
في يونيو 1940 تم حبسه بسبب
الورنيش الفصل بالقرب من nevers
حيث هو جميل بفضل
أصدقاء فكريين
هرب بنيامين إلى جنوب فرنسا
يصل إلى مرسيليا ويكون الأول
محاولة مؤسفة لمغادرة
فرنسا نختبئ في سفينة شحن
25 سبتمبر 1940
مع مجموعة صغيرة بقيادة
ناشط ضرائب شيوعي
عبر بنيامين الحدود الفرنسية
الأسبانية
بعد مسيرة شاقة استمرت 9 ساعات و
ريفا يقودك إلى كاتالونيا
تقدم لرجال الشرطة الاسبانية مع
تأشيرة الولايات المتحدة
لكن للأسف تأشيرة العبور الخاصة به
غير صالح
يسمح له بقضاء الليل عند الباب
نوبة نحن في انتظار تسليمها إلى الجستابو
غدا
بينيامين متعب ويائس
الانتحار ليلة 26 إلى 27 سبتمبر
8 مساء. بنيامين عابر سبيل بين ال
الثقافات والثقافة الفرنسية
الألمانية وترجمته proust لديه
أحب باريس قال باريس هو أ
مكتبة عبرت من قبل المشهد
سيكون بعد وفاته هذا العمل الفريد
من نوعه
بعنوان عاصمة باريس في القرن التاسع عشر
إنه طريق طويل
بين المنشور الذي يزرع
كراهية الذات والآخرين
وغيرها من الشخصيات التي تحمل
تصل قيم مجتمعنا
إنسانية
للأسف السيد زمور يستفيد
من مناخ الأزمة الاقتصادية
يفضي إلى تطوير الكلام
كره الأجانب والعنصرية
إنه يستهدف جمهورًا مليئًا بمزيد من j
g مدمن على Bolloré TV
انه الرعب في غزو الأرض و
ممارسة وقحة في الدمج
لا يزال باه يريد كلمة من أصل عربي
على الرغم من كل شيء لتسهيل
استقبال هذه الأكاذيب في
الجمهور مات لا يوجد
الفرق بين عربي ومسلم
عمارة جيدا قاتل عربي أفغاني ن
المهاجرون طالب لجوء كلهم
المسلمين في جميع أنحاء العالم
بما في ذلك معجم الظلامية
كل القطط رمادية
لا ينبغي أن ننسى ذلك أيضًا
زمور جزء من تيار
الفكر المألوف في السنوات الأخيرة
انحطاط القرآن
في الشخصيات الرمزية يسمى
ارتفاع هوية آلان فينكيلكراوت
ميشيل غير سعيد onfray ارتفاع
الانحطاط ميشيل houellebecq ارتفاع
التقديمات ومارسيل روك أيضًا
مؤلف فهم التعاسة الفرنسية
في زمن أبناء العمومة ومنطق
زمور
لفهم كيفية عمل exe moore
اتخذ نفس الوصفة لكراهية
الإدارات والدبابات الألمانية تتكاثر
أدعوك لقراءة الكتاب
رائعة من قبل المؤرخ جيرار
noiriel
النبيذ قبل إدواردز الريشة حقًا
اريك زمور والجانب المظلم من
جمهورية
وأن نفهم
كيف استغل إيريك زمور
القصة التي أدعوك لقراءتها
كتب المؤرخ مع روبرت
باكستون القماش القطني في فرنسا
نحب بعضنا البعض لا تستسلم
لا لصفارات الانذار من aisne
شكرا لك على اهتمامك وعبثا